the other thing that they're going after
is the idea that the United States is
exceptional and the United States is
exceptional again why does nobody leave
what give me the second best place
give me give me one place that's better
it's a better way to phrase it give me
one place that's better Hannah Nicola
Jones give me one place that's better
AOC and why don't you go there instead
of just complaining what a racist
patriarchy here and wasting so much time
trying to destroy what these old racist
white people created why not go
somewhere else there's got to be
somewhere in Africa you want to go
there's got to be somewhere in Asia that
must be much better I'm sure those Asian
countries aren't racist at all I'm sure
there's no racism against other Asian
people in China or something like that
so they want to destroy the very
Foundation of America which is the idea
that we are exceptional because then you
can put aside all of your nonsense your
skin color and those things and then go
get what you want and that's what they
hate here's Sunny Hosten of The View
the problem that I have is with this
Narrative of American exceptionalism
exceptionalism that we've been taught
since we were kids I mean I I set the
Pledge of Allegiance you know all
through my life in school and then when
I got into college I took an
African-American history course and I
started realizing that the actual Pledge
of Allegiance doesn't apply to a lot of
our citizens well they weren't including
us yeah it hasn't met the the dream of
being exceptional it hasn't met this
country hasn't met this dream of being
this beacon on a hill and so I think to
the Supreme Court has already ruled you
can't force anyone to take the pledge
but I think until we really meet the the
the
promise of what this country could truly
be then we shouldn't be touting us out
as as exceptionalists
Sonny leave I really mean it leave
America go somewhere else that you think
is more exceptional go somewhere else
where you can accomplish your dreams
you're a Millionaire on television every
day who just rails against the very
system that let you an untalented hack
who is not bright nor interesting nor
Pleasant uh it has allowed you to become
super rich and influential
so maybe there is something wrong with
America come to think of it actually now
that I'm thinking about it a little more
clearly America really did screw up
because it allows people like Sunny
Hosten to become super rich and
influential and everything else uh the
American founding was good the Pledge of
Allegiance is good the ideas and these
documents were aspirational they were
just people of their time who had to
Grapple with slavery and with inequality
and women couldn't vote and all those
things and we've consistently through
time just one after the other knocked
down the barriers that that stopped
people from being equal
[Music]
foreign